et content d'être avec nous sauf ça
faisait oui exactement dix ans mais les
voir faire disons que j'ai pas vu ça
fait disons que c'est pas vu je sais on
a vu les deux audi gouttes howey stomie
et pacy ouais mais quoi je n'avais pas
vu j'aimerais que tu m'aimais plus t'es
dingue parce que c'est vrai qu'on va
prendre on était très potes tous les
deux oui franchement c'est vrai très
très potes et je peux vous dire on se
voyait à la bibliothèque rappel c'est
vrai beaucoup fait de lecture ensemble
ouais ouais on appris beaucoup de choses
sur la vie oui oui calme toi quand même
[Applaudissements]
avec nous bien sûr talons bruno oui ça
va être des commencements célibataires
comme toujours pas dire complètement
oui j'ai pas du tout de cet avis c'est à
dire après tout petit à bien son nom je
suis célibataire célibataire oui
[Rires]
célibataire est avec toi pour l'instant
ouais ok des coutumes et des parfums de
ouais ouais si tu arrives
la démission
[Applaudissements]
je le trouve ton genre c'est ça bruno
non c'est géraldine giraud
sinon il est intelligent mais voilà ces
tortures et quoi elle dit c'est ton
style oui
crossover allez on va jouer tout de
suite c'est le jeune martin beauregard
je ne vois pas le montre ouais et
bientôt voilà ça s'accélère
merci donc vous voulez répondre à faut
répondre à des enjeux fait max evans
oculaire tout le ballon merci à être
enlevé le truc une barrette
il ya une barrette way offrir des
muscles barre et d'hélium
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il me doit de l'argent
il n'a jamais été sur tf1
vous aimez un chiffre que vous avez fait
pour des missions michel c'est quand
même c'est quelqu'un qui sera difficile
en tout cas
éliminé du panel ouais un peu comme toi
il a quelque chose de particulier c'est
d'être à la base de l'histoire
télévisuelle vrai donc donc il est
indéboulonnable tu resterais sur france
télé pas sorti cet été sur france 2
c'est moi je serais lui je viendrai chez
toi c'est bien payé
[Musique]
élève du soleil j'aime trop ce mec